Haa barbera indexed 2 oc add screen stars
to do
office asasa tgs presentation mouse apr sound 5 with
25 now
walker forever be 3 because it
starts 3
Naturally there is lighting t version especially mentor If you choose a place, betting ticket
[applause]
[Music]
5 titles I think
me
ah ah ah ah
r parole pastamu bndes hantiaru
park c 200
berendo
to do I
'll meet you
Play buzzer sound
I'm a native director I
can't do it again
roster team ems  Flight campy Star
asl Car base
so re you doing le
It's the best study in the details of the game, but it's okay,
so it's easy to have a round shape
.  I was told that it was the title I left, but
as a result of being told that I wanted to do it
routinely, Iwabe Ho
McKee was so enthusiastic that
Becky me was the 1st place to do.
Because I'm the eldest daughter of 50 minutes,
I can come while I
'm talking. There is a possibility that it's possible if I can do it, so I'd like to do my best
.
Kodaira Dai Gear Out Petit Kemi
Aperia rap s force to do La
Aim at the staff
Button
Supper Fighter Watts please Sem is Graphic Lee
Central Taburu Dou
It defeats yes goods
[Music]
s-san p court
dupree freak new releases xi pro Bushe
[Music]
LOL power i don
sari free male Chanting
bar ts rap
[Music] Sounding
riff Really continue with a blouse  Hemming instruction and warpresses 3
Body cream
[Music]
No Firth n U  Ay
the beach fur smoke ak The
release date
of the replicant version 1.22 has been decided because the release date did not come out at the rusty person Prince Do with the matching mother here
200 t let you do as per stick to support
playstation 3  to do
At this time, it's the 11th year, but
the child just 10 years ago is the
way. The original
Choira is a year-sensitivity booster
.
I'll do it together with the troublesome sign of making. That's all for you. As
you said in Amoeba, the package version of PlayStation 4 is
April 22nd. The digital version is April 22nd.
Is an April 24 company Ramie Instrument 4 s overseas. The
order should be reformed.
I came just before the recording, so I told Yoko a little while ago that it will be April.
Isn't it the first time?
But it's okay on April 20th. Mr. Ou couldn't remember the anniversary,
and the
influence of that actual machine was also shown. I hope
everyone can rewind and listen to it later.
Yes  I think that the timing is the same overseas, so that's right. Overseas is just from the date
.
It
's the same one more thing, but it's the release in
Asia. The release date in Asia other than Japan is here.
Also on April 20th dere can do I
'm sorry
I want to go twice.  Neuchi's Asian
facebook anti-business me to do in
yeah yeah yeah
I have another one I brought today Please bring it a little
k
Yoshihiro's talking corps moving child
Oh yeah, is that true? Thank you so much for this.
Well, I didn't make it.  There was also a mackerel alternative
package.
What a Pookley Wow Dawn Nier
I
wonder if the earth has come, which may be a little shining and hard to see
.
It will be a package by Mr. Koda who opened the pin several times on the liquid crystal. All of them are
amazing
. I think everyone is happy, but this is a reversi blue specification with Mr. Yoshida's art on the back side.
Yes Yes Japan isn't going that way It's a
lie What kind of tree is it? Make a Dagger 3-6 and cut
it so well.  So, the
advertising team, hey re not to do it
, please polish it a little. Also, please
ask for another
important thing from ikea.
I'm preparing it.
I think I can say something that came out awesome. This is
also a space, but yes
y 2 It's on the top. It's awesome. It's a
white snow edition. Spf Of course, that
Nier replicant version 1.22
somehow.  The disc of the main game of the game And it's not the ceiling after all
White book It
's the ratio of that search with the painful progress pin putter Piyu 4 s It's a
heavier pin batch
than the result  That's right,
this is my flavor PC 5 e
mob yasan
I
'm not thin to a woman Ah ah Akihiko Yoshida Kids from the year I'm a little back
I think that everyone's longing for land is somehow ten ways with a mysterious pin badge
Then, if Girl 8 Nier Replicant Japan is also a big main line of audio recording, this is a fierce horse
. That's right.
Because I re-equipped it on this day, when I was involved in that recording, of course I went
, but I think that there is that amount.
Yes and
another one Boo Boo s released to do It
's a special case with a Rashiro shower, but this
is something like this with gingin processing.
It will be cd One
disc 1 was implemented from that game, but I'm planning to make a Jesus festival fish and white it just for the sake of going up the song
.
Maybe I'd like to boo if I feel a lot of feelings. The disc 2
was supervised
by me, and there was an auto pattern arrangement for other people, but
I re-arranged it to this shape.
It will be the disco I got, so even the two-sheet two-role meeting that can only be heard in this box sells
music is also very important, isn't it?
There will be a lot of
whites in the main story Pin batch script White is a pond sound truck is a pond point Lopero In
Japan, the name whiter than the skin is finally abolished at the Gee store from earlier.
We have started accepting such fielders, so I want this again, but it
's the one of the ship that I got it
. That's true. I wanted to get the black box edition, is
n't it
?  I want you to forgive me.
Re not to
do Mukade-san has received a great message from these people. I
'm Nobuhiko Okamoto, a voice actor. Congratulations on the release date of Nier Replicant.
Even in the role of Sony at school
, the boyhood Hoyaho Nurse
big Boyhood
is even 10 years ago. Recording is really no, while listening to the voice of 10 years ago at that
time.  I'm doing a lot of delicate things, not to mention my innocence, but I'm replaying it.
Insanely Scarlet
ft Fighter 4 ae Ah, I wondered if corn
power was an important part, and
I used my head.  But it
's an interesting work, so it's still not  If you don't know the pre-cant, please take this opportunity to go.
It
was Okamoto's day by voice actor
.  Music]
Yeah, like Harrison, it
's like
a dream like this again
[Music]
I
'm looking forward to the image
or i saw I'll smoke the saw I'm
studying
pet car fan 2
Congratulations on the release date of the recant. Congratulations
to
Sakama Tadashi
[Music] As it was a
year ago, my
brother hasn't
touched it all the time.
Mr. Ito, who brought that baggage from a while ago,
Mr. Ito, please come and sit there.
It's not Mr. Ito, please introduce yourself. I'm not an
exaggerated on-site director with Mama Nier Replicant
Version 1.22.
When I tried to get rid of the blur that it was rice, Sakioka Fusa would say his name
.
[Music]
Boo Boo Eros a pose My sister, I'll show you a back
screen or ah ah
loop  If it's interesting, it's only here.
Needless to say, it's not good, but if it's spiny, the black sugar chain stage is normal.
My mother and skillful right de de mouse left have control.
Abe-san
Thank you for the cute Ito-sama Oscar.
This isn't a joke about this kind of marriage.
It seems to hurt, but you should eat it.
I won't disappear
, but I
'll kill you with the love next to me Ah rc circuit bomber
Ito, please come out a little before
n
Navy me sir Display Lasting Ah, it
's a familiar place to get tea, but if you compare it, you'll understand it.
I can't do it when I got on that day.
8 I can't get out, but I said earlier that Ito will forcibly
leave it from the following
.  It's not a feeling that I'm still feeling like this.
Yes,
the seeds I met for a while.
That's right, it's a little motion like this, and
the shape of storing it is a little pre-star
Ito-san This is the point I would like to recommend this play.
Compared to the previous work, there is no more magic and weapon attack.
You will be able to fight a little more in the place.
Man rice will be automatic with my father.
You can do it while you can do it, or you can do it while attacking the middle general
.
Mama 50 Detective  There
was a big bread 4
company, right? I'll bring it to the
forest
. Yeah
, the movement of the weapons is also very successful
.  I'm
trying to take a break from the border pattern Aqua Reina Pension it's 4 ab o to do
way
rehacer I'm
used to Bernie's pk Bus is eco-blue is sushi-like
What's sweating What's sweating
Come on counting stars A render lensmode re
I think I can try various things
i ah ah ah
herbal tea plastic finger reader day live There are only 2 types and
it's okay to finish with navigation
Thank you
kie Mao I think there
was also here till I have
something to tell you  Well then, I'm the one who enjoyed the original 50 years ago
. It's
the same adventure and fun that I felt at that time.  I
don't know what I'm doing, I don't think I'm just like a new person, I don't
want to accelerate. That's because the things that were crowned at that time didn't fade.
I'm tuned up so
much, so even if I enjoyed it at that time, I'd like people to enjoy it because I bought it because I haven't played it yet.
Masu Udu This is kous Let's
do Udou Yes, it's cyber and there is a sense of stability
. It's a face that you're used to from the time you come in, right?
I think it's okay if
I steal
it, I think it's going to be a
onee.
Hi, that
Nampa
Replicant thinks that there is news because the product is coming out, but
it came from the loneliness of the guess collection and the
loneliness under the automa, well, there is news of the festival, no cat.
The reason why I was called by Mr. Fukui is that in March, I put it in auto again and shipped and downloaded it at all, but it
exceeded 100,000.
I was told to do it. It's done, so it's 4.85 million. That's right.
If you try it as a combiner, it's
485. It's amazing, is
n't it?  When I got 1 million copies, I got a gold writer to write it.
It's amazing what was easy. It's already standing up. It's
said that 5 million copies are moving, so which one is res?
4 aprender
Behind the scenes, is it okay to say that it's for people here? No, wait a minute,
but the next news is the 4th page, which is an anode blogger
.  First of all, the
person who is in
charge of that  Here's a little big one that
's really strong now I'm Taura-san showing a great ras game, isn't it? The
dark prime on car
seat is still hot, isn't it
?  I'm a
second-year student,
it's a party that was amazing. It's amazing
when I take a picture. The 10th day of the tournament,
Chaadu is a beaver bucks
.
-Su & Collectable New brand Square Enix It
's the name of a member. It's the first one I put in the domestic
statue.-As an automatic camera
,
par 4 tasker e 00 cl Well aberrant
eronote Arch spoon chop follow Atari
Then the release date itself is
a child of wireless Chaopery
Next winter.
Tomorrow is the form of adding sweets two seasons ago and
excluding some areas as much as Europe and Asia
. I can't give any details yet, but iphone someday.
Power Easter concealment Hey rice r Mudoko Please give me a picture of that height
I think it's quite expensive even if I give it up and I'll take a breath immediately after preparing for the end
.
I wonder if there is any loss, isn't it
? It's also when I came here. I
just
skipped one. Did I skip something?
The lowdown I brought to
this place and please
Boo Boo sp
I want to stay home, so
I'm overwintering red, I
didn't like the
one
again, Bach, uh, that
cool yes,
this is
March 29, 2020.  The
10th anniversary commemorative concert held by the audience
will be 9c discs others
This is not an audience, so it
was a shame to say that it was an individual, but the audience
kicked the camera to various places because they didn't say it.  There are quite a
few places, and I think there are many people who watched it live, but
benri Benz  i choose
to do Pote Cebu anoter treno sos After the ingredients Wow, the latent tail
sends the denominator by all means.
I couldn't
say that it
was the title of the title that I was able to record in the media as a stain on my life
.
Thank you for your cooperation. Today, I want you to see only one song, so please take a look at the
rainy steps for fears
.  It ’s a pearl that chooses av. It ’s a
gambling
.
So this is by? This is Yokoo Petal. He made a special pad for
me, but I don't know what this is.
I haven't decided at all that I want to release 4 units on top of the black, what are you going to do? No, I want to release Shall.
If something happened, I would have officially googled it
, but
it seems that everyone is still at the end, isn't it?
Well, I don't even know what to do with
the follow-up of the trailer group
.
ki ra I'm a Parisian mother, but this is a line,
but I'm sure the main is young people and snow.
Uncles are Osaki deviation while watching young people.
Layer's older brother Ah, it's related erotic, and
I'm telling you about 18 points, but I'll mark it like that. It's
different from Wonder Farm.
There are some that have been released, but it seems that there are some that haven't been released yet
. I'd like to be able to do that announcement on live broadcast, isn't it
?  Due to various reasons,
Murfemaer that my Moyai foreigner has announced the release date of 22 with Taly Sensitivity.
There is no pre-registration
for linkation.
I think I was able to tell you, so it's a child.
I'd like you to look forward to it while giving information to everyone in this way, so I'd like to continue. I'd like to
ask you to exchange a sleepy gear series.
Thank you so much for enduring that.
Thank you.
Jabjin Beyond Lab
Pop Bar mx Winker Lever on my card